as a viewer I've watched all of your
seasons and I think that we should ask
questions that's a good idea yeah about
each season oh God I'm not I don't like
those kind of games I
feel like Randy Brandy believes
everything she reads and everything she
sees shut the [ __ ] up
no you shut the [ __ ] up don't tell me to
shut the [ __ ] up don't talk to people
like that too
[Music]
[Applause]
you just tell my friend to shut the [ __ ]
up
I think Brandy can take it back a notch
Brandi doesn't like being confronted and
she has no problem sticking up for
herself me I turned tail and run out the
door I swear to God in my life I'm not
doing anything wrong you have to have
compassion for All Humans but she
doesn't learn I think she tries to load
she's dumbest door not all as involved
like you're evolved I'm involved she's
always
let's see these pictures but okay I'm
glad you just said that because what you
no no you're not going you can you see
how you said it to us and we took it
exactly how you meant it that is not
going to resonate over there being able
to like Kiki with us I mean like [ __ ]
that that doesn't literally go over well
because if they call me a [ __ ] then I
know that she was saying it you know
what I'm saying so watch your words I
feel like they're all waiting to pounce
on anything one person I agree the
problem is that
Brittany has a Target on her back now
like Vicky doesn't want to like brandy
let's just call a spade a spade okay she
is not getting any passes from any of
the other ladies when I think she's just
making a simple mistake and just being
herself because she's really a fun girl
they are making an apple Tartine for us
oh my God that sounds delicious I hope
it comes with ice cream some ice cream
yeah what you told me what part about
the waiter well that mean let me just
yes yes okay okay so it was brought to
our attention earlier that possibly you
accuse the waiter's wife of being a
lesbian what made you think the lady was
a lesbian her eyebrows
[Music]
I never heard anything so crazy in my
life her eyebrows
so ridiculous maybe she knows because
she's a part-time lesbian what are my
eyebrows giving
that's the real question I mean this is
where I start to fall in love with
branding it was done common all right so
or the eyebrows on campus
there's no such thing as a lesbian
eyebrow there is
generally I can tell if someone's a
lesbian why her eyebrows
what would lesbian eyebrows look like I
will tell you when I see them it's
different for everyone
oh my God I don't understand the drama
no because you know walk up to someone
and say that it's just I mean
yes you did you saw his wife and you
walked up and asked him if she was a
lesbian
he just said it on camera to us if you
shut the [ __ ] up for two seconds
Taylor is literally yelling at me
but all I can think about my head is
that stupid cat meme
told you
for wine
[Music]